c'est ce courrier qui a tout déclenché
une lettre datée du 17 novembre 2016
envoyé par le conseil départemental elle
pose problème parce qu'en fait on nous
interdit selon la première lettre de
nous rassembler en association en fait
on nous occulte complètement c'est dire
qu'on nous dit depuis des années on nous
dit de nous professionnaliser ce qu'on
fait à on prend du temps sur le samedi
pour aller en formation quand même et de
l'autre côté on fait comme si on n'était
pas capable de gérer des temps d'accueil
collectif pour proposer des activités
aux enfants pour proposer la
sociabilisation
samedi dernier une quinzaine d'entre
elles se rassembler à versailles au delà
du courrier elle souhaite une
reconnaissance de leur profession ce qui
concerne le salaire c'est sûr que c'est
un peu compliqué parce que pour avoir le
smic il faut avoir trois ou quatre
enfants deux fois et plus le temps de
travail cr c'est beaucoup beaucoup moi
je suis à 45 heures par semaine avec
trois enfants n'a pas de santé on n'a
pas de médecine du travail
on n'a aucune obligation d'aller voir le
médecin on a juste une fois par an va
voir le médecin qu'il mais apte pour
continuer notre travail pour avoir
l'agrément
selon la cgt plus de 8000 assistantes
maternelles travaillent dans les
yvelines